- former UBS banker Bradley Birkenfeld
is next on book TV he describes his
involvement in the Swiss banks practice
of sheltering billions of dollars for
American client
thank you please mix up the home enjoy
food in the beverages I just want to say
a few words here tonight because I think
it's so important to express my deepest
gratitude to all of you for coming
number one and off your warm welcome
here to that National Press Club where
the official launch is my book thank you
this is so many people that were
instrumental in this process of writing
a book which is not an easy task I went
through this or many years of course the
assistance of my publicist Kathy Lewis
Wikipedia set up at John Hawkwood
publisher Greenleaf and Austin Texas my
literary honey arraignment my web site
development came off the bike and came
to Massachusetts and my ghostwriter
sweetheart top who was really
exceptional sent a lot of time with me
and put up with my nonsense a new
hampshire writing to the book so he
really captured my voice I think you'll
all understand what you read the book
that the talents the story finally the
true sword not the spin not the
government side not you yet inside but
my side and I think anybody who knows me
knows that I'm here it's the whistle
blow I don't have to lie I'm on this
alone so the sword really hit home I
think you know how other whistleblowers
as well by doing what I did exposing the
largest and longest-running tax fraud in
US history
it has forever change the landscape of
offshore banking not just in - at the
limpid around the world and I've tried
vigorously to try and assist and help
help other countries as well as my own
government
unfortunately my own government didn't
really like what I had to say and I
think we all understand why this
happened when you affect the rich and
powerful people in this country you get
the short end of the stick and it's very
easy to ridicule and criticize me when
in fact
all the bigwigs are doing all the bad
nefarious acts took on the biggest bank
in the world UBS and I took on the
biggest government in the world the
Department of Justice I still feel as
though that it's important to keep up
this fight because not just from my
cause but for other people down the road
that might be adversely affected by
their actions so whistleblowers in
general I think we all know who they are
what they do but they're instrumental in
being an essential component of law
enforcement law enforcement is better
off because of whistleblowers they're
easier the quicker they're smarter and
they can get right to the cause of the
problem and correct it how do you expose
waste fraud and corruption generally
it's the powerful people doing it so the
only way you can do that is by having
the people inside exposing that and
tonight we are honored to have various
of lawyers here that I've been very
fortunate to meet and interact with over
time Thomas Drake the NSA whistleblower
John kiraku the CIA was aboard robert
mcclain the TSA whistleblower Fred
Whitehurst the FBI verse of law and
certainly just one Radek the DOJ with
the Lord all of them a different story
but all of them work for the US
government and why would they attack
well I think you can draw your own
conclusions on that leanness and it's
sad because they tried to destroy your
lives they destroy your reputation and
destroy your financial future this is
something that has to stop if we don't
stop it if we don't collectively solve
but then it will continue and this is
not good for public policy whispers are
continually harassed and intimidated
retaliated and ultimately fired from
their jobs and this is something that
really does it make sense and I think if
you go back around fifty five years ago
in this town the very famous words John
F Kennedy said to my fellow Americans
ask not what your country can do for you
asked what you can do for your country I
think those words are a rallying cry for
every whistleblower to stand up do the
right thing
correct what's wrong in this society and
make the stand
sometimes it's horrible I think that we
will continue to have problems if we do
not continue to support and protect and
pay whistleblowers hey the whistleblower
is not the primary reason for
whistleblowing but certainly it
alleviates some of the problems they
face when they destroy their whole
financial future or their family so a
lot of these whistleblowers have been
thankfully supported by the nonprofit's
in this town the National whistleblowing
Center taxpayers against fraud Project
on Government Oversight and Government
Accountability Project just to name a
few I've dealt with all four of them
they're very professional they're
relentless and they help the cause and I
think we should all really applaud those
folks for what they've done but we must
ask ourselves why have we been
mistreated in the lines and in the case
with UBS when you set that for a moment
and think that the bank is not fine
properly they did not get all the names
properly and they let the kingpins walk
away what's happening in the end here is
the Swiss taxpayers had to pay this
because they wrote it off as they lost
the corporate bank wrote it off
so the people who had nothing to do with
this had to pay for it additionally the
UBS shareholders had to pay be
outrageous legal bills to cover for
their illegal nefarious acts not just in
the US but worldwide
so two groups of people had to pay for
this this is the problem and if it
doesn't get rectified it will continue
as I said so this is something that's
very very serious it says that bad
precedent as well as there's no
deterrence so if you feel so you can
just break the law and write a check
well it will continue and Wells Fargo is
perfect example of that as a present day
story
but really in the end when I think about
why AdWords successful in money endeavor
to stand in front of you here today
it was around four years ago that I
wasn't allowed to come here when my
three attorneys made the historic press
conference here with the award of 104
million dollars I call them the
modern-day Three Musketeers
Steve Cohen difficult Pinto and the
observing they may not like that label
but I thought it was appropriate but you
know we my brother and I who was
instrumental in helping as well with my
book as well as my very good friend Gus
lated who I worked with for many years
at stage 3 Bank was went out of their
way and they were very helpful getting
this book delivered to what we have this
evening and I think if you think back to
the US Constitution if you want to know
what the US Constitution says you ask
Thomas Jefferson if you want to know
what the IRS whistleblowing law says you
ask Dean's Irving why they wrote it they
know what's going on and I have deep
gratitude for my attorneys as they said
and Michael Cohen as well didn't want to
leave the fourth musketeer out likely
and I think it's important that we all
understand that we have to come together
with the nonprofit's the whistleblowers
the attorneys and the public who all
come together to help these folks rally
and weather this storm which is really a
very hard so on
so I really want to thank you again all
of you and my attorneys for your help
and support and I couldn't have done it
without you thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much if if there's anyone
has any questions I'll be more than
happy to answer them as well as to sign
any books afterwards for anyone who
would like to have them signed as well
Bradley Russell Mulcahy from corporate
crime reporter as I said to you this is
probably one of the best corporate crime
books and there's two stories I liked in
the book I like a lot of stories in the
book if you could tell the two stories
one is about how Hillary Clinton
prevented the 16,000 names from being
turned over to the Justice Department
and about your time in prison thank you
for the question and thank you for the
confidence in the book actually what a
spider-man book that was pretty good too
no I think I think the problem we have
here is that I don't want to become into
a political he-said she-said but this is
a detailed in my book and it's very
disturbing because WikiLeaks thank you
to WikiLeaks exposing the behind scenes
negotiations in Switzerland between
Hillary Clinton as Secretary of State
her counterpart calmy Rey the problems
we have in the situation is is that in
any crime that gets committed you have
to get to the source find out who was
behind it and and hold everyone
responsible the problem with this case
was for years they've never been able to
practice with them ever so what happened
with this case was they were so afraid
of these names coming out as they are
today so we had 19,000 fives at UBS and
they negotiated Secretary Clinton
negotiated for 47 hundred that's 25
percent so that's a 75 percent failure
rate I think we would all agree if
anyone fails at this job 75 percent to
be out of a job so why did she do it who
picked the 47 hundred names how did that
happen who did it
did she pick them did you did you yes
the one who's been breaking a law victim
so this is a real very dangerous
scenario and we still don't have the
answers so that's the first problem one
you only got a few of them to you don't
know how to we're selective and do we
really know do we have a third-party
accounting of 47 hundred names or we're
just going to trust me so that's the
very this is a big big problem and all
of you are being cheated by the way this
isn't just about me in my book it's
about every American who gets cheated
because they didn't do their job right
so then those things come in now what's
happened with the others well they had
one amnesty they had a second annecy and
they have xxx and around 55,000 people
have come in over the last six years
approximately so we only had 19,000 a
UBS only but 55,000 so they came from
other Bank as well obviously you can
19,000 people I won't even get the DOJ
that lecture but the problem here is
when you start looking at an issue you
if you don't get to the issue of what
these people were doing how do you know
that you've solved the problem you don't
and certainly I'm just going to trust
the government that say they've done a
great job because why didn't they
uncover in the first place this is a
real real serious problem which still
exists today because we sit here if that
money then moved to another jurisdiction
maybe it has something even more
nefarious or someone gives up their
passport and says I'm not going back to
the US this is what I told them I said
you must go after the source because if
you don't eradicate the cancer it will
match the size and that's what we have
today we have other governments now
chasing the money down UBS is moving the
money to Singapore to Monaco to other
jurisdictions this is such a big problem
and nobody's addressing it
genna's because they don't know it like
I know it but still this is what I told
them ten years ago and they did y'alls
when he's open
I went to something called the
Correctional Institute it was called a
camp and actually there's a funny story
when I went in there I am they put me in
the green guard for my photographs on my
ID and I always wanted to play a
psychological game if you shall weakness
they'll take advantage of it social
strength so I felt enough I'm going to
smile for the fathers's why is - I'm
here to have fun
wizard said on this rock so you know
what really dangerous people there with
the camp there's no prison cells there
was no fence but there's some
interesting people that are there with
but I went out of my way to help them I
helped them do their little Appeals I
helped them try and get an attorney to
fight for them give them a little
glimpse of hope while you paid for these
guys that were selling a dime bag of
marijuana to go to jail for five years
40 grand a year so it was the most
ridiculous thing I ever saw
god-fearing lawnmowers and snowboards
that you pay for food clothing that you
pay for Union salaries which you pay for
prisons which you pay for and you don't
see this until you on the inside and
that's the sad thing so again it takes
insider to see really what's going on
it's a hit wait a minute let's stop the
bus this is not right you want this
thick do you think the guards going to
police themselves now so it's a real sad
thing but I went out of my way to help
others is what I did place the boccie
little tenant works on one side van watt
will track read a lot and and I knew I
was right and I'm still right to this
day and I'll continue to say I'm right
and I got vindicated with the awards and
I think that it's not just the money of
course it's a large amount of money
thank you money for business but I think
the main thing here is is that it
vindicates me in my eyes maybe some of
you can say well you know we get it for
the money now I started this whole saga
long before the law was ever even passed
so what about money about doing the
right thing and I think that's what we
all do as much as long as we do the
right thing but everybody wants to turn
it and spin it into something else
that's exactly why I'm here today trying
to rectify that
thank you any other questions
stiff Colin Hauser
could you tell me if you think that
Congress failed you when they brought
the hammer that went DOJ brought the
hammer down I'll tell you what's the
most disturbing part of the story one of
one of the many facets of it is the
United States Senate when I first
launched the Department of Justice was
with my first law firm which I fired and
then sued I I should have gone to the
IRS but that didn't happen when the DOJ
demanded that I give them the names I
refused because I said I live in Swift
the one where I would go to jail the
same excuse UBS used in the Senate
hearings but when I said it long before
they said it I am the bad guy so I can't
do it I'm not giving their names so give
me a subpoena so we won't do it that's
it [ __ ] you that's all I said to him and
I went to the Senate and I ask my
attorneys get me a subpoena at the
Senate because if I give up one name I
go to jail and system where I lived at
the time so this was very very important
and I was trying to follow the law where
I would reside it this was very
important so anyways I go to the Senate
I give him all the information the names
and everything of course they shared
with a detail that was working for the
IRS who obviously shared it with DOJ
took my information indicted me could
add the product with the nomination so
to this day the US Senate will not give
me my Senate testimony not your
testimony my
ten years later I still don't get my own
testimony this proves I was right and
the prosecutor kept them down in Lodge
to a federal judge in Florida realize
it's a fact because I think with whole
baby names my tenant when I read the
testimony he gave the name long before
he was ever my vitamins ever run play
guilty this is what else about our
government how corrupt these guys are so
they twisted and turned it around and
make it look like I'm the bad guy
well if you just give me two subpoenas
you could have had the names and it's
incentive testimony which I can't get a
copy of great job so that's one part of
it that's very very bad so I think the
Senate never called me to testify an
open public because they knew they'd
start hearing what I'm saying now and
it's very dangerous so they had me there
they never call me for the vial case in
Florida I was the one who identify him
that's why they have him extradited from
Italy but never called me and he was
acquitted and I have proof that he was
breaking along this country in intense
crazy you know that's just one example
of how I think the Senate was unfair
never called me to testify in public my
boss testified but he plays a fist and
he had a secret non-prosecution
agreement which is in the book by the
way so he sat there with a
non-prosecution agreement which means he
has to testify and he pled the fifth and
the DOJ sat there and did nothing I saw
that easing the better than felony you
can't plead the fifth if you have
immunity but of course why are they
going to tell lemon anything because the
DOJ was playing the game get him out of
the country and he quickly left the
country was free to go back to
Switzerland
cynical give Katya follow crest of the
of course that'll be quite candid CIA
used Sakhalin to move a lot of money
through switzerland just go back to iran
contra general c course it's all there
instead of testimonies senator graph we
had hearings on this back in the 80s
about POWs in the Golden Triangle it's
all there they were laundering money
with the Afghan drug trade payoffs okay
that's the CIA they do their business
whether you like it or you don't but it
exists but the problem here is is that
when I first came to the government the
DOJ
they set the target letter to the bank
by the way we know you're breaking the
law we're just going to let you know
we're investigating you know that's
wonderful so what they did was they tip
their hand because they use too many
rich and powerful people going to be
exposed that's why everyone above me all
the way up to the Chairman all got an on
prostitution nobody wins nobody was
prosecuted in the United States or
Switzerland for UBS except no whistle oh
yeah I did there's many more banks to go
after but that's and it's my mom is it's
almost a sure you keep making up it's so
unbelievable but when I work with my
attorneys and they were looking at the
information of how this couldn't have
happened this way but it did but see the
thing is again when you look at the US
government and searched government I
always said that they're in bed together
I said that on Thom Hartmann show the
other day I'll say it today the problem
is very simple is that
there's too many interests at stake and
I'll give you one last example with
respect to UBS
back in 2004 when I was working at the
bank there was a situation in which UBS
was not allowed to send wires to Cuba
lívia or Iran because they were in
sanction countries so UBS was doing that
for years they were sending millions and
millions violating that faction Federal
Reserve comes in on
100 million oh ok that's interesting so
the laws of sank in the world is sending
millions of dollars to these three
countries they're told not to do it too
well who represents the US interest in
Cuba Libya and Iran Switzerland UBS
physicists Bank so if you're that you'll
be a Jew and that the Swiss government a
guy like me just a crumb crush in we
can't go down that path how they come up
with 100 million dollars just like out
of thin air just old sound sexy from
great again you've got cheating as well
they continue to do the illegal business
no one lost a job no one went to jail
wrote a check by the jack no problem
right right your senator and say why
won't you give him his testimony from us
um
that's the first thing the second thing
is why doesn't the Senate hold hearings
on Kevin downing and how he misled
Congress he had an oath of the US
Constitution and he violated it and
called me as a witness to testify under
oath in public that's what I like to see
happening not just for me but for any
other whistleblower who comes forward as
well as all of you in every American
taxpayer we need is the deserts to know
the truth and hold these people
accountable because they're they're out
there still doing this that's the
problem if you don't stop it it will
continue
yeah importable hope all that better
yeah why do you believe that
whistleblowing is such an important part
of public policy well again as I said
before thank you for the question I
think we will all agree if you look at a
certain parameters and this is what I
said to one reporter in France if we all
witness a woman outside getting her
purse stolen we public report it right
it's the right thing to do on the other
extreme if we knew some rogue person
wanted to ignite a nuclear bomb in this
country we probably taught them to it's
an extreme example but right the two
trees so that means if you agree with
that statement everything in between
should be reported as well if it's
illegal waste water corruption right so
as a matter of public policy we're
better society if we clean out the
illegal acts the waste fraud and
corruption first hold the people
accountable second and then we're a
better society as a whole it sounds very
simple to say it but it's true you know
everyone says all while you ratted on
him or you told on him as look if you're
breaking the law and you're adversely
affecting us don't you think we should
hold them accountable whether it's in
the pharmaceutical industry the finance
industry the military industry and so
forth do you draw a line between public
citizens and the US government or not
well yes of course because I think
you're either part of the problem or
part of the solution and I think the
problem in the government is they are
the problem because they never like to
give credit to someone else certainly or
whistleblow because then they said well
geez you're expendable the whistle poll
did your job for you and I think that's
what I would steal one of that the DLJ
is that the government was so hostile
towards me but no one ever came out and
said oh it was always him he's the one
who came to us and so forth so nobody
wants to give credit to someone else so
I think that's really the problem in
practice certainly people want to come
forward but they're scared
and again the retaliation as I talked
about before is very important because
that really scares people and they're
not doing anything taking no action
Jennifer Clark sounds like Wall Street
nobody went to jail
nobody testified nor we tried nobody
went to nobody went to jail who do you
report to
Department of Justice doesn't want to
hear from you who do you report to
that's a great question um well see what
I did was that's exactly right
I mean if you think back to the
financial crisis that was the only way
to go to jail I mean it's quite ironic I
mean the whistleblower who brought
billions back to this country through
perpetuity so I think what I tried to do
to sort of answer your question in a
different way is that I went to various
different agencies so they couldn't bury
it
DOJ certainly would have buried this
story if I didn't go to the Senate and
the SEC and I think that was an
important part of what I did would tell
as many people as possible
so no one could bury it hide the story
and I think we see now that's exactly
what happened so agencies then started
fighting amongst themselves and coming
up with stories and you know we're going
to hold a hearing and so you can see
it's all about who's going to take the
credit and you're right what happened on
Wall Street this is just absolutely
ludicrous why wouldn't you but again I
mean you saw the Tim Geithner with the
head of the Federal Reserve then became
the Treasury secretary and Eric Holder
worked in a law firm that represented
banks and then became the AG they're all
in bed together it's all the same it's
the revolving door there should be a law
passed you can't go into private
preference and even work anywhere near a
client that you had what it was from
government to private property
government that alone so it it's the
tougher yes
[Music]
well you can ask my team's if tonight
yes we did have a problem I'm a
determined individual and thank goodness
I had the proceeds to be able to self
polish but even though the the
publishing house that I used in Austin
Texas Greenleaf they were very nervous
about mentioning names and they were
very concerned about having
documentation that would be on
documentation my literary attorney Eric
here will probably differ with me
wherever you are but he was very good in
protecting my interest but no I think
the thing is is that when you're the
whistleblower you feel determined have
the truth told you'll do almost anything
to make sure it's sold and unfortunately
for those people that think they're not
going to be outed I haven't found a way
the album really but I was doing and I
don't feel threatened I don't feel
intimidated what are you going to do
he's taking your best shot in your loss
okay you put me in jail you did all of
that but now I'm exposing the DOJ for
their their corruption I'm going to
expose the people basment accounts and
there's many more now do I know all my
things out you know I don't they
certainly don't but how is it that this
existed for so long and no one did
anything so that's why I kept saying to
my Poppa sure look we need to come
forward and tell the stories so other
people are empowered they're galvanized
but say look if she did it I should do
it because if we say oh oh we're the
keys crushing his little ballers she's
going to scare people away from doing
the right thing on public policies the
public policy issue it's better for us
as a society
[Music]
different over my well you're absolutely
correct I didn't work for the CIA or NSA
but what part of the story in my book
Michael rauner when he was writing my
story the the station's the CIA station
chief in Baghdad Brandon said don't talk
about this guy don't talk about the one
exhibiting the book Abdul Aziz of ours
in the book that was the one man I gave
to the Department of Justice because he
was making illegal oil sales books
without him saying and they and after I
told them all this information and I
went through all the maceration of what
he was doing and how he did it 420
million dollars you can see the car the
cars reading the book is the myth of it
and then I said well and this is June of
all said and I said well I'm one of the
stood friends in New York is Rudy
Giuliani says we're not interested not
Americans it's tough to tan in my face I
said yeah but you don't understand we're
not interested well the prosecutor was
from New York obviously Republican like
Rudy Giuliani whatever you're not
upholding the law right they're wrong
you violated your oath to the
Constitution
you should been fired on the spot it may
be it may be the processes so the point
of this he had a 50 million dollar condo
in New York City and I walked through
all these things and he did nothing I
said but how can you ignore this one
client so you're going to go through at
the dentist to go talk to the Bootmaker
really when you've got an Iraqi national
living in New York City on the 46:47
floor of the Olympic town who is making
illegal oil sales for Saddam Hussein
so that was insane by the way I keep me
invaded this country in Calgary the last
I checked that's what we did do so
really so this guy was doing business
with this man and then if you take it a
step further when the cops'll Hussein
they found in with trunks full of $100
bills
what was the rest on the bills you can
get rats how convenient
jeez I guess he was too selfish doing
some shopping in Baghdad I said math she
fought in 60 minutes I have no faith in
60 minutes
none I did an interview with him and he
said well what do you think they should
do I said we'll see he said he wasn't
interested not Americans I said why
don't you go talk to the thousand family
members that died on 9/11 and ask them
if they care because the DOJ said they
don't care
now they cut that out now so I saw it
firsthand I saw the nonsense and if you
can't tell the truth and get out away
and this is the problem so people in the
government organizations you get
intimidated threatened whatever it
happens all the time but I keep telling
my story and I'll continue telling my
suni I hope you enjoyed the book crime
branch can you can you tell us more
about how you see the role of the media
in getting a story out and helping to
protect the wrestler and so on the
problem is very simple most of the media
nor thanks to the media here it's been
dead with the Department of Justice in
my opinion I'm not this some sort of DOJ
grants the problems I saw articles that
twisted the truth and what I began to
realize when I watched it very closely
was they were then rewarded with an
article later so they'd get the inside
tip on oh we're going to raise this
house and you'll get the scoop because
you did what we want to go over here
that's not clean press
that's not reporting that's quid pro quo
nonsense so unfortunately I think the
media today and I've actually had a lot
of luck with European media because
they're less influenced I would say but
there's some very good media folks here
in this country and I've had good
success with getting my story out but
it's a big problem and I think the
problem is is that that is now been
ingrained because people feel well
reporting is not like it used to be you
just want to hand it to you and it's
hard to do an investigative story and
really get to the heart of the problem
hi Brad oh hi Brad Kevin Callahan a huge
fan of the story I do have a question I
feel a little uncomfortable being in
Washington and asking this question
there we go
taxes are a very relevant issue today
and I'd like you to shed a little light
on you know what you feel about that
subject well look everybody would love
the payroll tax let's face it you know
taxes are something that we have to pay
in a variety of ways whether the gas tax
income tax capital gains tax inheritance
tax some people feel as other excessive
some people say they're not enough okay
you could have that argument all day in
general what we pay taxes for is to get
something in return
some sort of service whether it's the
police fire road schools you name it I
think the problem we have in this
country is is that it's so big and it's
so diverse and the backgrounds are so
different that you'll never agree
obviously the tax code is a mess on the
corporate side clearly with all this
offshore nonsense with Apple and GE and
hewlett-packard moving money to offshore
keeping them off floor but it's regal
because the code allows it they do it
now you be an idiot if you didn't do it
so change the codes let's just change
the code and make it simple bring the
money back and foreign banks and put
them back in American Bank put the money
here and let it or a Kia better it's a
very simple solution but there's too
many arguing counterparts to this
discussion on the individual side of tax
I've always believed a flat tax the
three-tiered flat tax makes sense get
rid of all of the nonsense that the
paperwork get rid of all the accountants
the lawyers and all of this is not that
people should be able to do their tax by
themselves not a tiresome to do their
taxes and that way it would make it a
lot easier now it's easy to say for me
up here but I think it makes sense I
think everyone would agree that you'd
say ok 0
fifty thousand to pay ten percent fifty
to 100 you pay twelve and then fifty to
whatever to the sky you pay whatever
something like that and it makes sense
no deductions now there's some people
there with education and low-income
families and welfare benefits of course
some of that has to remain I guess that
that's fine but it can be worked out but
the problem is that the IRS system is so
complex
if you can't your own taxes that's a
problem and you know I listened to
Warren Buffett one day say you know well
then all my secretary please more intact
than I do
yeah because she pays income tax you
jerk you pay capital gains if you gave
her shares in your company
she'd pay capital gains you pay the same
rate you did what do you what do you
think what do you think we're fools I
mean for him to make such a comment like
that I don't care how much money he has
it's ridiculous and then he says well
we're against these inversions and then
they take Burger King up to Canada
doesn't inversion hey so anyways I mean
it's just you know sometimes you wonder
where these people are coming from but
why would you make such a statement to
throw your secretary and use her as a
guinea pig in their argument it's
ridiculous and so I have issues with
some of those things but in general it's
a complicated issue I think there should
be a three tiered class tax system and
the corporate stuff should be able to
come back and just get it back in this
country and cut out Europe you open yes
thank you now that you finish writing
your book what's what's next for you
what are your plans I think part of the
book is there to tell the story but to
also motivate other whistleblowers to
come forward and do the right thing
hopefully that comes out in this so that
they see that the system is a little bit
slanted against them that doesn't make
me motivate them but at least gives them
a clearer image of what's out there and
what you do going forward the other
thing is to to lecture to do this around
the world I've done it in Europe quite a
bit and I can continue to do that
because I think it's important and to
take and support whistleblowers in these
initiatives so I think that's a big part
of it but then to hold as I say the
government accountable as well because a
lot of government officials over in
Europe were shocked that my sword they
they couldn't believe it so it's are we
a bit mounted here is that just to be
sort of go with that is it is it just a
standard operating procedure in this
country so this is a problem and I think
that attitude has to change now when you
go to Europe the other problem is is
they're not into this payment award
system but I said well you have to
understand where it derives from back to
Abraham Lincoln this is a very old law
very successful law and it helps
everyone recoup these monies so Europe
has to get their arms around that a bit
and I spoke to the assistant finance
secretary of Norway and she was very
open to the idea she liked the idea of
the award the way I said it was she
focused on getting a whistle on award
say 90% goes to the government 10% would
go to the whistleblower but I said take
10% of that 90 and put it into a fund
just like your help fund your education
fund in Norway everyone's covered so
let's say someone comes in with a
non-financial award whistleblowing case
teachers are getting kids for instance
then they've come and report it and they
would get some of that money from that
fund so in fact the financial
whistleblower award pays that one but
also helps non-financial and everybody
wins
again as a matter of public policy and
the risk you took to pierce that
extraordinary wall of swift secrecy and
then the suits of myself a few times in
terms of not just the US financial
system but the global financial system
what are the risks longer-term with what
some have suggested as a global
contagion I would say again the old
adage all the money is a very important
adage because money does corrupt I think
we all agree it's done it for thousands
of years and it will continue to do so
the problem we have now is is that money
will find a way to go in other
directions other jurisdictions other way
of hiding it whether it's physical
whether it's in other commodities and
people can be bribed through gifts and
so forth so certain countries don't have
the same rules and regulations that we
might have but the problem we have in
this country is is that you know the
United States and Panama are the only
two countries that don't agree with the
automatic exchange of information so if
a French person had an account in the
United States the US wouldn't tell the
French government but if an American
have an account of Paris if they hey we
want that information so why doesn't the
u.s. play by the same rules why doesn't
someone ask President Obama or or
Treasury secretary Lew why are you so
against this why are people paying
Castro condos in Miami in New York in LA
why do you have dictators laundering
money through our banks oh that's right
because Jamie Dimon is such a great guy
sandy weill at Citibank years ago the
great guy yeah great guys they don't
want to admit the truth the truth is
they're part of the problem and they
don't want to fix it now if that's just
the US what about some other countries
that just be like forget Dubai really
Qatar you know Singapore great countries
but on banking it's not the same you
can't even get into it even Delaware
companies where you don't know who the
shareholders are why it's too profitable
that's why so we will never get to the
bottom of this until we harmonize it now
I'm not saying worldwide but there's the
OECD and and the Treasury Department
should be pushing this and say no this
is what we want but you got to play by
the same rules guys as Europe if you're
going to put in fact tough you know play
by the same but they don't so it's like
we're running around in circles and I
don't see a solution because they're not
playing by the same rules if it's bad
and in the situation in Switzerland the
reason why I told them don't chase them
immediately and get all of these people
was because you don't want the money to
squirreled away in some places you'll
never see it again now they're even
smarter because they know what you're
coming after them for so now if I had an
account I then put it in my friend two
thousand French I don't have any more
they don't know you're talking about oh
I'll give up my passport get a second
Passport
no none of that can I'm I'm German
that's on this month is Venice there's
no way of tracing it none now they're
saying okay they're stopping money
movements and things like that it's a
band-aid that's not a real fix the fix
should really be getting deep down in
saying look we're all going to play
those same rules we're all going to look
at the way in which business is
conducted and we're going to regulate
that we're not going to have these the
Delaware companies where you don't know
the shareholders whether that's nonsense
in our own country we have this so
people hide behind
well that's exactly right
and I've always said Swiss bank secrecy
got extended and now it's just
perpetuated by the American government
they've discontinued it why don't you
give us all 19 thousand eight why four
people robbed a bank in Washington today
oh we just get the driver and let the
other two people go we sold 10 million
bucks so we'll give you back six and say
we're sorry
I mean he's mad but this is what they
did and you got cheated not just you you
+ 300 + + million other Americans have
cheated and this is outrageous why the
media is not touching upon it I don't
know as the media folks call it the
White House has sent them all I sent the
president a book he got it this morning
somebody's ready we want answers you're
right hi Brad standing ranches from each
story and a great read of read about 2/3
of it and it's a it's very racy as well
but it's a good reason are two things
the implications here that that worry me
particularly one is a developing market
the trouble with the story is that a lot
of money comes out of developing markets
right and it doesn't get invested in
education schools health care and we end
up having a situation where it's
hand-to-mouth
in many countries in Africa in
particular but other countries as well
the second thing is this you say follow
the money but if you have secrecy
jurisdictions in place in the United
States and elsewhere then you can't
follow the money and that includes
national security so if the fundamental
issue of is terrorism
national security Mexican cartels
the rest of it can you talk to those two
issues developing markets and terrorism
absolutely I think the problem with okay
if you want to cheat on your taxes
that's one thing you want to deny your
spouse the information they're not to
tell your spouse but that's another you
want to cheat your business partner
that's another way those are just basic
fundamental reasons why people had
offshore numbered accounts and super
fine in Africa the developing world is
suffering people are poorer than poor
I've been all over I've been to Chad if
in the Kenya I've been the tunisia
morocco all over and what happens is
when I was in Chad in 1998 Mobil Oil
gave them about two and a half billion
dollars they found oil 300 miles of
paved road ten years later there was
like maybe 300 miles of paved road it's
like where is this money going there was
no telephone lines there was no running
water it's almost like if you didn't see
a car you thought you were in the
medieval ages so when I saw this I
thought you wonder why Africa is still
in the dark ages you wonder why they
have disease you wonder why dictators
come in and they're doing the slave
trade and they have guns and killing and
oil and diamonds and goals and so forth
the rich and powerful controlling it and
all the other people in that
underdeveloped part of the world are
suffering and will continue to suffer
and there's a whole idea even with this
Haiti hurricane I'm thinking why are we
sending aid why don't we send down
construction companies to level these
homes and build new ones why because
this game they keep playing oh we're
going to send aids it doesn't work you
got to give them a home where they can
have a house of their head under house
but get rid of the garbage they have the
homes are destroyed so when we give aid
it doesn't really get there and it's it
proof-positive just look at Haiti it's
always been this way
continuing time and time and time again
so then if we come back to the applicant
scenario the problem there is is that
the rich elite dictators the money comes
up to Zurich it comes to Geneva and
they're buying homes in London for 50
million pounds is anyone asking a
question why no because it's too good
for the bank and the real estate company
and everybody wins
but the person down in their country
suffers okay so that's that problem
coming back over here you're absolutely
right
secrecy here it shouldn't exist Joe
Biden the vice president his faith is
the big promoter of this why doesn't he
say something big Joe
mr. mr. caring about people whether
you're democrat Ibaka I don't care the
fact is that's in your state you can't
see you don't know what's going on why
don't you take an active role in fixing
it and tell us your faces just like the
letter I wrote to the president tell me
what you're going to do mr. president to
fix it because if you don't fix it it
continues and that's the problem but
they're all benefiting their buddies
with the banks the big law firms then
they go and get a nice board ship when
they leave public office that's great
but you kind of fix the problem and
they're not so these two problems is
exactly correct I witnessed it I've seen
it and it's very very sad you know the
other questions
just to your point on Africa do you
believe the corporate responsibility has
anything to do with the development or
you're putting it non development of
some of these countries and you know
what is that fun to buy if I not taxes I
don't claim to be an expert on
development of countries but I think
that I'm smart enough to see that rather
than just throw money at the problem and
say I'm going to give aid or something
you should come in and have a concerted
effort to change the existing structure
meaning again you've got have a place to
hang your hat if you don't have a home I
mean how can you function and go to work
and have a job or something even though
even in the napkin under developed
country so give them that empower them
to have that first if you give them that
then people be like wow I have a nice
little home I can raise a family I can
have a job
well my home just got blown away by the
hurricane I'm living under a shack and
this is something that's very very wrong
but so knowledge money be given a
couldn't we just rebuild these homes
better and stronger and we don't and is
the personal pet peeve of mine because I
think that abate that fundamental right
to have a nice little home but we have
the technology to do that and we can do
it in mass quantities why don't we do it
you see these big helicopters coming in
and bringing aid I mean what is this
cost right outlandish what a claw so why
don't we just put the money towards
another effort and see if this would
work and if that works we will stick
with that program because it certainly
has it worked on this
I'm just a very interesting thing we've
got three devil agreed holy bread with
grease going going into the future with
requests for a and the wealthiest people
in Greece but they don't pay taxes you
might be a very interesting person to
for the Greek government dealers yes I
help the Greek government I'm happy to
help them
I had direct contact with the Greek desk
at UBS and I saw what went on there and
you have to understand when I say a gas
the desk is a group of people that are
covering a particular market so you
could have a Greek desk you could have
an American desk you could have an
Italian desk and so on and so forth so
what happens is you have a concerted
effort by these bankers to have a
hundred to 200 clients now again minimum
counsel has a million dollars when the
numbers get to see it's quite
substantial UBS in particular within
Geneva and Zurich predominantly in
Switzerland so you had massive debts
marketing to those areas so in
particular with Greece brief is a small
country but a very fluid country it's an
island nation so it's very easy for a
platform business to take place but it's
also easy for money to move around as
well so UBS took advantage that they saw
that we're at here in the u.s. they're
not going to get on a plane and fill a
suitcase on the gas and five engineer
maybe in the 60s but you want to do that
map now over there there take this
operate with different rules so it was
much more easy to do that type of
business
plus they had company set up in the
regulation and enforcement wasn't as
tight so I think you have a big big
problem in some of these countries that
are little less regulated little easy to
do this business and a lot of this money
was also legacy money several
generations that's been existing
offshore I mean look at own assets I
mean he had the biggest monocle for
years bragging rights
I mean it was quite an incredible thing
so you see this enormous wealth and I'm
not against people having
money if they've made it legitimately
but the problem is when you're sucking
it out of a country whether through
corruption and bribes and extortion all
this that's the problem if you don't see
you've got a big welcome well I would
think I would disagree I think the money
does get to go and hide now even though
you think it doesn't but it does because
these people are smarter than us and
when you don't you do not prosecute
anyone at HSBC for laundering billions
of dollars of drug money
that sends a wonderful message that's
the problem and the Treasury Department
all of them should be kicked right in
the butt because what they're saying
here is oh well we caught them but we're
just going to have to either check great
again another check that's fantastic so
again it sends the message to people
break the law do this business just
write your check and you're done
everybody bets etc what's fascinating to
me is people inside governments also
benefit from non prosecution one of the
things that I did was look at who didn't
pull the trigger in your case and just
before I came here I used the lek City
of the Google to find out what law firms
they were and what their salaries and
it's quite a sounding and my question
here is is you know what it's this root
this revolving golden door you and I
both know that whatever we incentivize
you get more and we are incentivize line
seeing the cheating and we're
incentivizing through that holding your
non prosecution where does it stop well
this is the problem if you don't do
something about as I said it master
thousands the cancer continues and I
think first for many many cases I mean
look at JPMorgan looking countrywide
look at Wells Fargo look at HSBC look at
UBS
the list goes on and on and I don't have
to you know delineate everyone but you
can see the common denominator is
prosecutors don't want to get their
hands dirty Oh
or it might be a favor of someone higher
up so they don't really do anything and
they just come to an agreement to write
the check
so everyone benefits as we said before
but again as I said a new BS case this
was taxpayers foot the bill they had
nothing to do with it and UBS
shareholders over here footed the bill
for those legal bills that they never
should have paid and the guys who did
the problem walked away so I think what
we're saying here is that there is a
pattern of conduct that is going to
undermine society and we're seeing it
because now all of a sudden we keep
asking so why do these keep recurring
because you don't uphold justice that's
why and I think we'll see it in other
ways down the road will become much more
dangerous and these Bank and bigger and
bigger and continue to do the problems
that we see today so if you don't uphold
the law and
lawless country but they'll say no no we
take care of this we do it now you don't
you pay favors and you know this we'll
get the Y deferred prosecution agreement
you've been cheating on our tax code in
our securities laws for decades so we
should just sort of turn a blind eye and
that's what I said the US government's
embedded system it's clear when I was at
UBS you could help in an account with
account opening ones and say Los Angeles
but we needed the client signature
confirmed
well the tie could go into the Swiss
Embassy and get it done so they're
aiding abetting tax evasion I told the
governor I went on issues matter well I
said I am let me think about that for
saying that was worldwide so the Swiss
embassies around the world would confirm
your signature to open an offshore bank
account which you would then sent back
and we don't really count
wonderful that's it sure incredible
any other questions hi Brad I'm David
you and I have spoken in the past some
founder of the whistleblowers dot Intel
let me um we've been in operation since
2012 and we've talked to the FBI the CIA
the DOJ the OCC that said the US
Treasury um they've all turned their
back you know and I know that today
they're moving masses of massive amounts
of money using correspondent accounts
it's all debits and credits
there's no Swift and it's worse today
than when you revealed the UBS American
taxpayers the reason why the deferred
prosecution agreements are so popular
today is because that money doesn't go
into the US Treasury that gets dispersed
by the White House and your question so
my question is it was bad when you
revealed the UBS situation is worse
today I don't see any hope and you which
a question on this so my question is
what's the benefit of a whistleblower
coming out in trying to do his civic
duty by showing corruption and
government corruption and banks
corruption wherever what's worse the
point because if the government won't
protect you and instead they'll try to
prosecute you why take the risk
well that's that's thank you for the
question it's an age-old question and
this is what we are this is the essence
of my book to try and tell people to
have the courage to come forward and do
the right thing yes there are risks
there is and there's big powers at be
whistleblower we've seen it with all the
whistleblowers I mentioned here this
evening so they've all suffered in their
own way and some harder than others but
if we don't make a fan
and change the laws and Senator Grassley
who is the champion of whistleblowing
his past laws whose thought for people's
rights who held hearings on it I'd love
to have them hold more hands I'd love to
be a part of it but the problem is is
that if we don't unite as one voice and
come forward then it will be a problem
you're correct and I think what we're
seeing now is in Europe it's slowly
catching on to protect whistleblowers
and some laws have come about just to
protect them but it's a move in the
right direction but it's not perfect
clearly and certainly the people in this
rooms are evidence of that so I think we
need to have stronger whistleblowing
protections I think we need to have a
Department of Justice held accountable
and I think if you've got to go on to
whistleblower but not a big institution
or global institutions what's that say
about our system so I tend to agree with
what you're saying but if we come as one
voice and come together I think it would
be much more powerful and we need people
up on the hill to make some changes and
hopefully that will work in our favor
any other question
the more efficient no one's lawlessly
father no no me Collin sleep Brett I
just want to say that I guess as you--as
citizens we should all thank you for
turning your life upside down yes you
came out with a nice benefit but it's
been a long road to get to this point I
wish you well on this look and I would
like to vociferously challenge the media
to carry this forward and keep this
message going because it seems like
that's the only way it's going to happen
if it stays in the public view well
that's it and that's the reason for the
Balkan the lecturing and so forth and
thank you for that I think it's a it's
quite humbling and I think it's
important for everyone to understand it
could happen to you in one way or
another where the government turns on
you and you're you're you're defenseless
because they can pretty much put their
power of the government behind
themselves to crush you in many many
ways
I had a gentleman prison with me joe
nachio a quest he refused to give the
Bush administration the names of all the
clients after 9/11 now AT&T and Verizon
caved and he said I can't do it I'm a
public company you got to be mississippi
'no so they came up with some charge
backdated options and put him in jail
for seven years they spent thirty
million dollars defending himself and it
was just it was if you read it it's
quite amazing to see what went on and
this is this hysterical knee-jerk
reaction after 9/11 a horrible thing of
course but why but then on my side of
the coin when we were talking in prison
together I said yeah I gave them alpha
Osama bin Laden's biological brother he
had a 14 million dollar account he lives
in Cambridge Massachusetts won't want to
go after him now no connection I didn't
say that in my opinion the best family
but granted you think well there's a
connection and you might want to go down
that path you think but they had no
interest in doing that and then I told
them when I gave the accounts of the
Middle East desk in UBS in Geneva they
said ah that's a nothing account we met
up several billion dollars that have
been Laden family oh that's nice to know
you understand that you know one of them
just blew up two big buildings in New
York City
you wouldn't want to go there right you
wouldn't want to just one essence of
investigation and cover all your base
against not because you might not want
to see what you uncover it's enough well
thank you very much I think
[Applause]
thank you
I very much
[Applause]
I'd be willing to sign anyone's book so
they want your books I'd be happy to